[Music]  [Music]  right questions  [Music]  yeah the only thing chemical philosophy  and the afterthought well only about  meaning to use very only honor of  stopping him hunting and shooting let's  now go back to the other life before  this life is live where your first  memory after being born leaving as a  child I mean the able to our next hassle  I'm noticing my father's that I'm on  across the face I'd hide my door and she  was crying  [Music]  price of being unbearable following my  every move  anyone who le analysis American if it  took anatomists the exactly down so will  you marry me I thought the whole thing  was a sterile cockatoo night is so  grown-up and he was Diana kindergarten  teacher and husband she did she  [Music]  I once heard him on the telephone say  whatever happens I'll always love you  and I told him I listened at the door  we're sorting out  [Music]  [Music]  and I realize I take it on the enormous  well I had no idea I was going into but  now I do  [Music]